all right I had to reload this I think
it works can you guys hear me now should
be able to see me Oh microphone is not
working all right
I think now we have everything we need
all right we got yes we got sound and in
it just two things need to go together
all right great
all right let's see so we got a few
people in here it's good to see
everybody okay so I've got I've got
quite a few questions a lot of questions
that are kind of development questions
but before I get to the questions um I'm
going to make I'm gonna give it some
information I have a lot of have all
these announcement that I'm supposed to
make all the time and I always forget to
make them so I'm gonna make them here
hopefully those that actually follow me
will will see the Q&A and so um as you
guys some of you know every year I give
a few icon carving classes and so this
year there are two icon carving classes
planned one is from June 9th to June the
15th and it's in West Hartford
Connecticut the other one is from
September 1 to September 7th and it's in
Salem South Carolina and so the the icon
carving classes they are they're a week
long and we we don't we carve all day
but it's actually for those some of you
that have actually done them they're
actually also a great opportunity to
just kind of spend a lot of time talking
so I actually usually give the whole day
and so I'm there from about 8 9 in the
morning and then I will stay up until
late at night until you know people are
tired and want to go to want to go to
bed so usually it starts with carving
and you usually end with sitting around
drinking beer and and and talking about
all kinds of stuff so so if you're
interested in that I will post the link
in the description once this is when
this is finished being live the called
Hazara on school
iconography alright I am also going to
be it seems I'm going to be in Paris
March 26th and 27th for an event called
iconographer is Without Borders I was
just asked this a few days ago and and
I'm and I'm gonna go so it seems like
it's like 95% sure that it's gonna
happen it's it's at the Russian cultural
center and I'll post all the information
on my website and then in the
description as well so if you're French
I suppose it can say hey Mountain Valley
francais if we've made up a he and and
then also yeah I'm gonna be in Seattle
on May 17th and the 18th there are a few
people organizing a conference called
growing in the likeness of God Eastern
spirituality in the modern world and so
and so I'm gonna also going to poison
pose details to that but if you're in
the area and you want to come see this
it's going to be with father Stephen
Freeman and a few other few other people
that are going to be giving talks it's I
think it's like it's gonna be like a
full day of conferences and stuff and
I'm gonna be one of the speakers so so
it'd be great to meet some of you in
Seattle or in Paris or you know in
Connecticut or in South Carolina so come
if you can
all right so then then the other thing
that I wanted to talk about is I got a
lot of questions in the last videos
about the newly the newly fangled you
know very special art that I put up like
I said I'm not totally done with the
background I'm probably gonna paint
actual colors because now mean it's ok
but it's still not not good so I'm going
to I'm gonna go through the different
art pieces that I have behind me and so
hopefully you will so please that be
interesting to you
so if you look over here this is a
drawing of Saint mamas and it was it's a
preparatory drawing for a huge icon it's
the actual size of the the final icon
and it was done by Father silouan just
in Yano and so as some of you know I
have this project where I draw different
things and my monthly I make some
drawings and so I created one of my
drawings with father Sela Juan for for
the drawing up st. mamas and so the
store
the reason one of the reasons why I put
it up for it well I think it's an
amazing drawing father Silla wand is in
my opinion one of the best
iconographer in North America but one of
the reasons why I like this drawing is
because I feel like it really represents
us it represents what we're trying to do
represents what I'm trying to do in this
in this moment let's say this historical
moment so Saint mamas
their different traditions about why
he's represented that way but one of the
main traditions is that as he was going
he was empty he was going towards I
think he was going to Caesarea he was
going to a town and he encountered a
lion that was about to eat a lamb and so
he saved the he saved the lamb and then
he got on the the back of the line and
rode the lying it into town so he rode
into town on the back of a lion and he
had a lamb so there are different
traditions some of them talked about how
he tamed this line because he was thrown
to the Lions to be eaten but then he
tamed the line there are other
traditions that he became friends with
the Lions in the fields there but the
image which it was interesting about the
image is really this idea of holding so
you see say mom is holding in his center
this precious animal this pure animal
and he's kind of holding it on himself
and and let's say in his centre you
could say and so but then he's also
sitting on this wild beast and so he's
taming this wild beast carrying this
precious innocent animal and so I feel
like that's really what we need to be
doing today is not be naive about the
situation of the world understand the
the shapes of culture understand what is
happening but use that tame that you
know in order to be able to carry this
precious hidden thing you know the the
hidden mystery the heart all that all
that stuff so that's what I feel and I
feel like also you know it's trying to
interpret popular culture but then also
trying to point you know the the aspects
of popular culture which can actually
point towards the logos is is what I'm
what is a
I want to do and so and obviously the
lamb of course represents eschatological
EU also represents the logos itself so I
love that drawing I think it's great so
I'm really happy to finally put it up
okay so behind me you can see so okay
right here so this is a little icon of
st. Michael which was painted by Anna
GREs EV allegory EV is one of the
teachers at the exam Iran school the
school that I told you about earlier
in terms of where I teach my carving
she's a wonderful iconographer
everything she she works very in a very
pristine manner you know very simple
very beautiful let me break it down for
you guys all right I always have a chair
there sorry about that alright so this
is a beautiful little icon of st.
Michael I really love it
and so yeah I'm not gonna bring back all
this stuff that's back there but yeah so
that I kind of say Michael then right
here is an Ethiopian cross that I bought
when I visited Ethiopia in what is it
2009 I guess 2010 um you can also see
right here is a little Celtic cross that
I one of the first carvings that I made
down here is also a an icon of st.
Christopher that I designed but I
actually didn't then carve this one I
designed it a very long time ago when I
was in Africa and I had an African
carver carved the basic thing and then I
finished I did some detail work later on
it actually just a few years ago I redid
it and we did some detail work painted
it and then added the gilding down here
is a little a little I hope you an icon
of st. George killing the dragon and the
mother of God holding Christ in her lap
so all of that you know the Ethiopian
cross st. Christopher and then the
Ethiopian icon I really really am
fascinated by Ethiopian Christianity as
some of you know I've written some
articles about it because it
really does understand its role as the
ark and it uses a lot of Marian
symbolism and so it has this notion of
this container and in a way it
understands itself as the periphery but
the periphery really in the positive
sense of the periphery oh you know so
the Ethiopian Christianity is somehow
kind of on the edge of the world and it
represents this this edge in the
positive sense and so a lot of their
traditions have something to do with
that for example they have this whole
system of churches that are underground
they you know they have this of course
they have this tradition that they have
the Ark of the Covenant and so there's
this whole powerful tradition about
about Ethiopia there's an interesting
image in one of the churches where the
there's a portrait there's an icon of
the mother of God but the shape of her
body is the shape of Ethiopia and so
really is this notion of the earth or
the land as this mother and so all of
that is something that I really
appreciate in in Ethiopian Christianity
so so yeah I've got a few mighty to open
things of course of course up here you
have my brother's book you don't see it
so well and this but usually my videos
I'll I tried to to to to show it a
little more of course as you all know
Matthew's book metier has been a huge
influence on me all through my life
you know his he I feel like his thought
you know although I can talk about
symbolism and I talk around it I tell
he's always shooting arrows you know
he's he's got a knife and he slices
through his his writing is so concise
and very precise so if you haven't
gotten my to his book yet seriously what
are you doing you need to get his book
you need to read his book so so yeah and
so then up here is an image of Adam and
Eve around the tree you can see the tree
and then there's a serpent coming down
the tree with with the fruit in its
mouth and then Adam and Eve are holding
a fruit also in their hand and that
actually comes from Haiti I traveled to
Haiti twice in in the early I think
2012/2013 to do some work so do some
humanitarian type work there and so so I
got that there and then finally is my
little God's dog poster and a few people
asked about like what is God's dog I
know some of you who watch all my videos
have heard me talk about this before
so God's dog is a graphic novel I might
share my brother and I we wrote an epic
story a long time ago we wrote it we
finished writing it in 2009 I think
around 2009 early 2010 and it really is
this epic story about about st.
Christopher the dog headed Saint and so
st. Christopher's this dog headed
monster like like in the icon over here
and in this story it has all the
symbolism that I'm telling you guys
about is they're in story form and so
there's that garments of skin there's
st. George they're Dragons they're
giants there are pretty much every
single character from Genesis is in that
story so we wrote it that we wrote it as
we actually wrote it as a screenplay and
we were very naive about how how movies
work um
and so and so we wrote it as a
screenplay obviously that didn't go
anywhere but now just recently in the
last I think we started about a year ago
we started to transform the story into a
series of graphic novels and and so the
story is all fleshed out the entire
thing the whole mythology the whole
world is all is all fleshed out and so
now we're putting it down in a book the
artists name is Courtney Olsen and he's
very talented artist were going for a
very kind of simple simple style kind of
cartoonish but with some detail as well
something like Jeff Smith did in bone or
you know in that style so that's kind of
what we're aiming for and the first book
has already been completely thumbnail
the whole story is set and so now we're
going to start we're already starting we
already started to do the actual pencil
work cord is working on that and so he's
working on the pencil work right now and
so you have so pay attention in the next
few
two weeks maybe I don't know exactly how
long we're gonna wait until we do this
we're going to set up a crowdfunding for
the for the graphic novel it's going to
be we want to do it I think we want to
do it independently just because we want
to be independent and because we are we
are playing with some ideas which
although they're they shouldn't be
problematic they might be problematic
for some because we live in such a crazy
world right now and so so so pay
attention to that God's dog you'll hear
some news from me on that pretty soon
all right so I think we covered all
those basics is there something about
the art that I didn't say that any of
you have noticed and want to know about
alright so if not then wait I'm not
seeing all your messages this is
annoying all right okay all right okay
so here we go so I'm going to start with
the questions from the web site okay so
Jacob I'm at net stake of Russell asks
in your conversation with John Fein it
masu you drop the kind of bomb on the
very analytic conversation when you
brought up love being the key to
everything so many are afraid to go this
to go to this topic or the yulie just
brush it off - its chemical hormone
makeup within our biology the day before
you gave us that preview I happened upon
like stories of all video about
interstellar in it he talks about
perhaps the underlying theme of the
movie
and the one no one is talking about is
love and can be seen around the
narrative of dr brandt saying quote love
isn't something that we invented it's
observable powerful it has to mean
something maybe it means more something
more something we can't yet understand
maybe it's some evidence some artifact
of a higher dimension that we can't
consciously perceive love is the one
thing that we're capable of perceiving
that transcends dimensions of time and
space something else that transcends
time space is memory and when I think
about
memory I think about do this and
remembrance of me or remember me when
you come into your kingdom there are
many other examples that link
remembrance and love throughout
scripture especially Psalms do you have
any insights on this linkage and or are
there any church fathers who speak on
this or am I seriously going insane has
read Shearer has warned all right sorry
I keep asking you ask questions I was
going to ask what your favorite color is
huh
as I tell my daughters I usually
grown-ups don't have favorite colors
pretty much I don't I don't have
favorite anything anymore I just yeah
it's like if people asking about that
for movies and stuff like what's your
favorite movie I know I don't think of
things in those terms anymore
I have a favorite sweater you've seen me
wear it it's that like really thick wool
sweater sweater that someone always
criticizes in the comments when I wear
it so all right okay so let's get to the
question so the there is a link between
love and memory this is the way that I
understand it I don't know if the church
fathers have talked about this
specifically but love is definitely more
than you know the chemical whatever you
have to you have to understand I think
this is the best way to understand love
love is the capacity for unity within
diversity or the capacity for diversity
within unity that's what love is love is
the capacity for things to come together
and be one be together without one thing
being destroyed or absorbs orb by the
other okay you know we have this image
for example in in Brahmanic Hinduism of
you know the returning like a drop of
water into the ocean like that's the
ultimate that's the ultimate
enlightenment you could say but for
Christians that definitely is not the
case for Christians the unity being made
one with God being being United to God
does that never negate your
particularity rather it is it makes your
particularity shine with the grace of
God it may
you make your your your personhood you
know become a form of glory of God and
so it that's the transformation that
occurs but we are not absorbed into God
and so that's what we that that that
type of relationship is what we mean
when we talk about God for and the life
of the Trinity is exactly that that is
the Father the Son and the Spirit are
three distinct persons three distinct
hypostasis that are completely and
utterly one and so it's an aporia
but in at the same time it is also the
key to understanding how reality lays
itself out the in an in an absolute way
it's an absolute representation of what
we experience relatively in the world
that is this notion that that we can
both experience unity and something and
multiplicity at the same time whereas in
God those two things are not not even in
a hierarchical relationship the one and
the many you know are are total you
could say they're total so that's a good
way to see it now ma'am now memory is
this is the way that I understand memory
memory is unity with something within
distance and so memory is the capacity
to be united to something to identify
with something despite you being far
away from it okay and so I mean just in
a general sense to remember something is
to recall and so you when you recall
something you are bringing back you're
participating to a certain extent with
to something which is no longer there
with something which happened a long
time ago and the same thing with someone
who would be far away from you you you
don't have them in your presence but
then you can remember them even if
they're far away from you now once once
that type of memory is brought you know
to a higher level you could say is
brought in to God or is brought to a
higher level
then it becomes it becomes a kind of the
it becomes the possibility of
participation in God and so when we say
you know when we say when Christ says
does this in remembrance of me and when
we talk about about the idea let's say
of God remembering Noah for example or
Jonah remembering God when he was down
in the the the fish
it's like Jonah and Noah were were at
the ends of the world they were in the
water they were in the chaos and then
despite the fact that they were so far
and they were so much in the darkness
then the memory connects them to God
even though that even no matter how far
they are it connects them to God so you
can imagine memory as the hierarchy as a
hierarchy which connects all the
different levels together and so no
matter where you are on the hierarchy of
being you could say if you remember God
then you are connected to God right and
that's the way to start let's say D
assent and so hierarchy is a form of
memory as well so the imagine it you can
imagine it like I always use a military
the military hierarchy because it's so
easy it's such a clear hierarchy you
know it's it's like the the the the the
soldier who's digging the trench is
acting you could say in memory to the
the commander who gave the order to to
you know to take this field or whatever
and so he's acting in he's far away from
that main that main order but as she's
doing this particular thing he's doing
it in memory of what he was of what he
received he's doing it he's doing it
being connected to the source of the
multiplicity of his actions and so that
is to me so that that is related to love
because love in a certain manner is also
is similar because it is the capacity
for things to be you know one in many at
the same time whereas memory is really
really is the sense of this that which
covers the distance you could call it
between between you and
and your origin or you and your goal or
you and your you know all that
so hopefully that hopefully that answers
the the question alright so cord Nielsen
just appears in the chat and so
everybody say hi to cord here's the
artist of our of God's dog our comic
book so so hopefully you'll get to know
him a little more in the next few months
I'm hoping to have a have a video where
I'm interviewing him and we're going to
talk about the the comic soon all right
okay here we go all right so next
question so Connor Magor I don't know I
don't know who these people are Connor
Maggie you get to use your real name
sometimes is it really okay Connor
Maggie let's see so thanks for doing
this Jonathan as a dare I say Orthodox
Catholic I'm struggling with the pool
towards orthodoxy how would you
recommend toeing the line without a
verdict aversion unless that's necessary
to leave the Catholic Church almost
feels like abandonment and an easy way
out given the depth of the rock but it
appears as if the hierarchy is almost
entirely corrupted and state-backed I
don't expect orthodoxy to be without its
issues I am blessed to currently attend
a wonderful TLM and Eastern Catholic
churches feel the area but they are the
periphery and are sure to face hostility
I'm sure other Catholics are in the same
position I trust though that this gift
of purifying fire will bring the
traditions back in harmony with one
another god bless so this is this is
what I this is what I think I I would
say that I'm not I not a Nick and I'm
not an acute humanist and I think it's
important to understand that I'm not
Anna cumin is in the sense that I don't
think that that it's all the same right
I think I've said this before I do
believe that there is a hierarchy you
know within Christianity I don't go so
far as saying that people aren't
Christian who aren't or
of course not but I do believe that
there's a there's a kind of hierarchy in
in in Christianity and it has to do with
being connected to the the Spirit you
know the front Emma as as the Orthodox a
that the the mind of the church the mind
of the fathers and so I do believe that
orthodoxy has preserved the most of that
and like you said in your question or
that actually definitely has some has
some serious problems as well but I do
believe that it is the place where the
the connection is is the is the most is
the you know is the most real you could
say um and so at the same time this is
that this is the problem you know the
the problem
this is actually a pretty good a pretty
good way if you want to understand the
the role of hybridity you know we've
talked about claim Christopher I'll talk
to you about about monsters on the edge
hybridity does play a role and the
Eastern Catholic churches I think in the
in the long story will play role because
hybrids are also bridges and we've
talked about that as well
for good and for bad you know and that's
why if you look at the situation of
Eastern Catholics for many Orthodox
they're seen as a major problem because
because they are this in-between thing
and because they risk oh the risk they
feel like they're a way to pull Orthodox
away from orthodoxy you could say you
could see it that way but you could also
see the the same thing the Eastern
Eastern Eastern Catholics as a way to
also spread some of the front mo which
the Orthodox have kept to be able to
spread seeds of that within the Catholic
Church in the hopes of transforming the
the Catholic Church see the the the the
the hybrid has that strange role just
like any transit
it can be seen as it can be seen as a
way to leave what's inside but it can
also be seen as a way to spread what
what's inside to spread it towards the
outside and vice versa right and so for
the Orthodox let's say for the Catholics
the Eastern Church can appear as a
dangerous throwback to orthodoxy and a
kind of in a dangerous situation we have
to make regular but it can also see for
the Catholics it can also be oh this is
a way for us to bring the the the
Orthodox into the Catholic Church and so
that's the situation with hybridity you
know it has positive and it has negative
and it's important to understand both
sides and so having said that I mean you
know I think that it has a role and you
know people some people will be angry
with me for saying that but I do believe
the Eastern Churches have will have a
role to play and if there is ever a true
reunion of the Catholic Church with the
Orthodox Church I'm not talking about a
political one
just for expedience I'm talking about an
actual theological you know
reunification between the two the two
the two churches the Eastern Catholic
Church is going to play a major role in
that and so that's that that's that's
the thing and this this event that I'm
doing in Seattle with father Stephen is
going to be organized by Eastern
Catholics and there are going to be
Orthodox speakers and eastern Catholic
speakers at the same conference and so
although I will not be taking communion
there and I like I said I don't I don't
believe in that type of of humanism I do
think that that's the space where the
discussion is going to have it so if you
want to have the discussion that's the
place to go into that's the place to go
speak so so I'm gonna be I don't I'm not
afraid of speaking there in that in that
space of transition so hopefully that
answers your question I think there was
another question later about similar
things so hopefully I'll have a
hopefully that I'll answer both at the
same time Conor Magor that actually is
your name Conor Magor sorry because you
just the way it was written in my thing
altogether it was like just Connor Magor
so now I can see that your actual name
in the YouTube YouTube comments all
right okay so david Flores asks I've
been thinking about the symbolism of
walking on water versus going below this
has been coming back with David for for
a few months as far as I can see
symbolically one ends in the
transformation of space journey to a new
place and the other a transformation of
self like be reborn through baptism is
this good interpretation and how does
one know when to walk or dive I think
that your interpretation is very
interesting and actually I think that I
think you're really getting to the key
of the difference because the walking on
water seems to represent the capacity to
master the potentiality right kind of
like sitting on the line right that's
that's what's going on when you're
walking on water it's like you're your
master of this potentiality or taming
the water whereas when you go down into
the waters it is a shedding of your your
your externals a shedding of the the dry
wood or the stuff that needs to go and
so I think that definitely your I think
definitely interpretation is good and so
is this good interpretation and how does
one know when we want to walk or dive I
think that I think that when you wind
you once you phrase it this way it
actually becomes pretty clear because
let's say walking on water would be
something like mastering your desires so
you know if you if you I don't know if
it whatever desire whatever this
excessive desire you have II usually
those are kind of like the desires of
the flesh you know you if you eat too
much if you if you have sexual to many
sexual thoughts if you you know if
you're you know if you're looking
watching pornography or whatever like
those type of things if you drink too
much if you're taking drugs if you're if
you're if you're hooked on you know on
some kind of opioids or whatever walking
on water will be
you know finding the capacity to to to
manage that chaos right cleaning your
room you know so cleaning your room like
the joint Peterson cleaning your room is
different from diving in and shedding
your extra your extra layers you shed
your extra layers when you really when
you realize that you that you've
accumulated too many of these of these
these peripheries but it's funny because
when I say that then I think in a way
that it could look similar just taking
it from a different perspective because
you know when you the things that you
shed when you dive in are the things
that you would also master that you
could remember then as mastering when
you walk on the water so I'm afraid I
just keep I just keep turning you into
the in circles sorry David I'm not
giving you a clear answer is people
gonna people are gonna accuse me very
soon of being a charlatan because I'm
not giving clear answers to your
questions
haha bucks day will write a book on me
about I'm a charlatan alright okay so
Luke Fleischman asks all right so hey
Jonathan I first want to say thank you
for all the work you're doing it's meant
a great deal to me and many others over
the past year and a half or so I have
two subjects I was wondering about so do
you have any updates on God's dog as a
lover of comic books this is probably
the most excited I've been for a comic
in years I'm curious as to what the
writer writing process was like did you
methodically plan out the symbolic
language of the story or did it
naturally lay itself out if I gave you a
little bit of a peek into God's dog but
in terms of how we wrote it you know
Matt's here and I we we often we kind of
share a brain in a certain way he has a
he has a real certain take on symbolism
and then so do I and so we really
understand each other it was a kind of a
mix of both I the original idea was kind
of mine in terms of st. George and st.
Christopher and then Matt's here he had
very good ideas of structure so
sometimes we would structure out a scene
you know
numerically with different characters
representing different aspects of
reality that would talk to each other
and so scenes would become extremely
complicated you know very almost like
geometric patterns and then usually we
would end up scaling down in order to
focus because it would get too too
complicated and so Matthew would work
really hard and like scale down the the
symbolism to - to some structures and so
there's a mix of everything there's a
lot of stuff in there there are some
ciphers there there are there's like
there's a hidden language you know and
there's there's a lot of stuff it's a
yeah I really I'm looking really [ __ ]
looking forward to to getting this into
your into your hands because I think
everybody's gonna really enjoy it all
right in the story of st. Christopher I
was wondering this is still Luke in the
story of st. Christopher I was wondering
what the significance of him coming
across specifically that of the Christ
child is I recently came across an
auntie of Padua and see that he too had
a unique relationship with a Christ
child
what is the difference of when coming
into contact with the Christ child
compared to one coming into contact with
Christ the man well okay so in the story
of st. Christopher
the story of st. Christopher is an
amazing story it is uh it is extremely
dense it looks so simple but it's
extremely dense one of the things that
is happening in the story of st.
Christopher is that st. Christopher is a
trickster figure as well I've talked
about this before st. Christopher is a
trickster feather this trickster figure
he's looking to serve the most powerful
being in the world and so he finds this
powerful king he serves the king and
then when he finds out that there's
another character more powerful than the
king he'll he'll trick the king you'll
say something like tell me about this
other powerful character and the king
will say no I don't want to tell you
because if I tell you you'll leave and
then Christopher will say well if you
don't tell me I'll leave so if you tell
me if you don't tell me then I will
leave you so the king is forced to to
reveal the secret of this more
powerful character and then st.
Christopher leaves and so he tricks the
the king he says if you don't tell me
I'll leave then he tells him and he
leaves that's a trick so he does that a
few times and then he comes to the devil
who's the most powerful the most
powerful in the in the world and he does
he he sees that the devil is afraid of
the cross afraid of Christ and so that
he does the same deal with the devil and
then the devil tells him about about
Christ and so secrets releases the devil
and then say Christopher is looking for
Christ but he can't find Christ one of
the reasons why I can't find Christ
because it's not looking for the right
thing um and so then he repeats this
month among tells him to go onto the
river and to cross people over the river
and so he's taking up his role as a
peripheral character first of all that's
important to understand he's saying go
to the edge of the world stand on the
edge of the world you're a monster
you're you're a dog headed man you're a
giant depending on the tradition go
stand on the edge that's your role and
then your role is to cross people over
and then he encounters the Christ child
so it's important to understand is that
Christ is going to trick Christopher
there are so many things happening in
that trick the the first part is that
the first part is that Chris that Christ
will trick Christopher in serving him
because he tells Christopher to take him
across the river so Christ tells him
says take me across the river
Christopher takes the Christ child
across the river not realizing that he's
up he's already there word where he
wanted to be what he wanted was to serve
the most powerful being in the world and
and so here's Christ tricking him not
only in serving the most powerful being
in the world but serving the weakest
being in the world at the same time or
what looks like the weakest being in the
world
so in Christopher in serving the weakest
possible being you can imagine a baby a
child he ends up being tricked
but then the trick flips back because
that child ends up being the divine
logos himself and and and then he
finally a
which is what he wanted which was to
serve the the the most the most powerful
most powerful men okay
second of all so second of all he also
plays his role you could say as a arc
and the arc the the purpose of the arc
is to preserve the seed to preserve the
logos you know and take it across a
difficult moment take it across the
difficulty of the world so it's a shell
right I've talked to you about the
garments of skin about this whole idea
of the shell so so Christopher axe has
this garment of skin the shell which
carries the the hidden logos you know
across the across the waters across
chaos okay so that's another aspect now
this is really the secret and I guess
it's something that I probably will make
a video on soon do directly on the
subject which is that the the hierarchy
of Christianity is different from the
hierarchy of the world I've hinted at
this several times but once you realize
that the reason of things is the source
of things the purpose of things the
logos the meaning that without this this
this spiritual aspect then the world
doesn't exist that that phenomena
organizes around these Logie around
these purposes and then you realize that
that the hierarchy is looks very
different because the logo the Logie the
the purposes are hidden they're hidden
in the world and so all of a sudden the
summit of the hierarchy the real summit
let's say the one which is even above
the the king becomes an image of
something which is which hides its its
power you could say which doesn't show
its power because because if you look at
the way the world is if you're
materialist if you look at just how
matter lays itself out you you're
incapable of seeing those hidden
Jem's the hidden purposes of things but
once you perceive the hidden purposes
then the image of that logos can be
actually can actually be the weakest
thing and then if once you understand
that you'll understand everything that
Christ says you'll understand everything
that everything that Christ says about
you know the Pearl hidden in the field
about blessed are the poor blessed are
the meek all of all this imagery about
speaking of the littlest one and
secretly being the highest in the
hierarchy okay now it doesn't mean that
being poor in itself has value right you
can be a poor wretched drunkard drunken
idiot right you have to be careful and
you know it doesn't mean that that that
let's say I that's it that's the best
example especially when we talk about
when Christ talks about blessed be the
poor the idea is that the like I said
the spiritual principle is hidden and so
those and so that's why you have
ascetics you have ascetics who want to
to to remove all those externals in
order to gather into the heart to remove
all the external to remove those
garments of skin and then move into that
hidden place and and those ascetics will
lose the trappings of the hierarchy they
will not look like the successful
businessman they will look like the
miserable like the miserable poor but
they won't be the miserable poor they're
the secret gems they're the secret
hidden pillars of the world you know the
monks the aesthetics the holy of the
holy people they they will not look like
that those who are the most successful
in the world they will have a different
aspect and so and so that's really
that's really the whole idea of the
Christ child the Christ child is always
represents the logos hidden in the world
that's why you see Christ sitting on his
mother and so it's like his mother is
this covering and here's this hidden
seed in the middle so every time you
hear about every
you you see icons or images that manner
that show the Christ child that's what
it's talking about is hidden seed
whereas let's say Christ on the cross or
Christ as it they're the image of Christ
also as the Emperor is also is also
totally justified right because here's
the unity of the principle like the
hierarchy manifested if externally
completely so the the external total
manifestation of the the hierarchy will
look like something like the the Emperor
sitting on his throne with a crown you
know with a glory around him all of that
it also also makes sense but the source
of that the source of even of that
Emperor is that hidden you know that
that Christ child who who's born in the
cave you know who's hidden in the cave
um I hope that make sense I hope that
makes sense
alright okay okay so alright so we're
done we have the website I'm moving on
to the SUBSCRIBE star questions so
Batman 23 hi Jonathan
my question is have you ever read read
Neil Gaiman's Sandman comics or any of
his other work he seems to have an
uncanny eye for symbolism and understand
the ideas of principality example the
character of a city even though he is
not a religious person what are your
thoughts on this
yeah I think that I think I agree I
think that Neil Gaiman's understanding
of principalities is very good I would
say that he is a he's a pagan in every
sense well I say that you know it's
weird because I say that you know that
I'm not sure that he's a pagan he seems
to you seem to want to wallow in the
lower spheres you could say that's maybe
the best way to explain what he does for
example there's one there's the one
Sandman comic which is based on the the
the hierarchy of a pair of Milton in
Paradise
lost and then there's the the Lucifer
character who's in hell but there's this
sense of this hierarchy of all and to
all the gods exist right all the all the
pagan gods all exist and then there's
this hierarchy of angels and then
there's God but God is is completely
transcendent you don't hear you don't
hear about it you know you he just
referred to and so it's it's an interest
it's an interesting idea you know he has
that right in that in that story but
what he seems to be interested in it is
just wallowing in this in this kind of
you know in the competing gods like
that's what that's where he finds his
interest and the question is whether he
does it you know whether he has some
weird kind of magical ability to to
understand these these structures and if
he's just doing it to tell stories and
to make money or whether he has a deeper
understanding of the one strange thing
is that he almost never talks about
Christ if he does I mean I haven't read
all of his books but I I did read
American Gods and I did read The Sandman
comics and if you read a few other of
his book hmm and he almost never
mentions Christ it so I really that's
one of the things that I would ask him
if I if I had him in front of me was
would be why why he he doesn't mention
Christ maybe he just doesn't want the
political backlash it's possible but uh
who knows
alright so second question by Batman 23
has there been a noticeable rise in
convergence of Orthodoxy I'm here makes
analysis that there may be more
convergence but the church isn't growing
what are your thoughts also why is it
mostly Protestants that do convert as
opposed to Catholics the reason why
there are more conversion but the
churches and growing is because the a
lot of the ethnic churches are not
capable are not don't seem capable of
holding their second generation and so
the ethnic you know the ethnic Greeks of
the ethnic Russians or the ethnic Serbs
they become to America and they think
okay somehow think that magically they
that their children will continue to be
Orthodox will continue to be Greek or
continued to be Russian
you know generation after generation
obviously if you come to uh you come to
this land you you your children will
assimilate at some point it's inevitable
and so they haven't totally figured out
how to to keep those other generations
maybe because they're presenting
orthodoxy mostly in in an ethnic as an
ethnic relationship you could say but I
don't know um but for sure well the
growth from Orthodox churches in in
North America comes either from
immigration or from converts so why is
it mostly Protestants that you convert
as opposed to Catholics oh I don't know
if it's Protestant it converts more
Protestants that convert it might be
true it might be true first of all
because North America is mostly
Protestant it might be true also because
once Protestants you could say bottom
out you could say they reach that you
know when they read the rock-and-roll
you know coffee house Church it's like
where do you go from there you don't
know where to go and so if you're gonna
the only place to go is to go back go
back to liturgical and once you start
asking those questions then yeah and
also because I think there's a reveal
that happens you know when you're a
Protestant not all Protestants in my
when I grew up let's say in the
evangelical church there was such a lack
of history it was basically like they're
Christians for about one century two
centuries but then it also already
starts getting weird and for sure by the
time of Constantine there you know it
was all it was all to hell and so it's
like you know if you start to study
church history then all of a sudden
you're like wait a minute well then all
the things you believe come from the
fourth century pretty much not
everything but a lot of the definition
that we use come from the fourth century
and so those are the same people that
are supposed to be the heretics I I did
a debate with a pastor a few months ago
and he's like from one side of his mouth
he was he was uh he was criticizing st.
Athanasius for his comments about
deification and on the other on the
other side of his mouth he was you
using you know the the christological
definitions of the Council of Nicaea and
so it's like you just you can't do both
of those things at the same time you
know you have to understand you know
yeah you have to take things together so
alright alright so John B asks hi
Jonathan how would you describe any
changes between now and two and three
years ago when the whole this began well
yeah my life has definitely definitely
changed I would say I mean at the same
time definitely for the better I'm it's
really been excited it really been
exciting to have all these opportunities
you know I was really surprised it kind
of started you know everybody knows it
kind of started with Jordan Peterson
kind of taking me along for some reason
and you know we had we had known each
other for about a year before but he at
first we we had people organized some
events with us together and so that kind
of gave some attention to what I was
doing and then it just kind of took a
life of its own
and so it's really exciting like I told
some of you before I never talked about
symbolism I would never talk about
symbolism before so now I had this
chance to talk to you guys to read all
your comments on YouTube and to to find
you know this little community like I
told you about the symbolic world
Facebook group where you have a few
hundred people that are there and you
have you know an intense group of you
know maybe just about twenty twenty-five
people that are really intensely
discussing but that's amazing that's
awesome you know to just to just
encounter people that are really
rediscovering the symbolism and it's
like it's a dream come true for me to
see this happening now and also to see
to see so many people going back to to
church going back to their own
traditions or becoming Orthodox you know
we're talking about hundreds of people
that have written me saying you know
that that that somehow you know this has
reconnected them too to Christianity and
so it's like I just thank God for that
and I I thank God every single day that
I have this chance this opportunity and
so hopefully I don't mess it up
and the same for you know for for the
speaking events I'm you I used to be
pretty lonely I would carve all day just
in my workshop all day and so now I get
to meet amazing people I am travelling I
meet people that are excited about
symbolism excited about Christian art
excited about that and so it's uh I have
to say it's been it's been awesome and
and a lot of it is is really thanks to
you guys who are who are engaging with
me we're writing me who were you know
engaging with the YouTube comments and
and also obviously people who are
supporting me financially it's like it's
just yeah my life is just not not the
same not the same person as I was two
years ago that's for sure so John B also
asks do you do any teaching at your
church either symbolism with iconography
do you make I confer your church so um I
try to be honest like I tried to be more
low-key in my parish let's say um for a
few years I was on the compares Council
you know I did that and I think that a
lot of people took them up it took them
a while like a year to even understand
that I was doing this that I was giving
these talks and that I was I was doing
these types of conferences and so so by
now I once in a while like I we
organized a few talks in Montreal I did
teach give a talk at my parish we're
planning another talk pretty soon and so
and I do have one at my parish I do have
one icon which is part of a piece of
furniture that I carved as a gift for
the church but uh but at least for now
that's about it but I would be very open
happy to just speak in my church but I
would always I always want I would
always want it to be to not I wouldn't
want it to happen too often because you
know I'm not a priest and so I don't I
don't want yeah I'm not a priest let's
just say that all right and so all right
moving on to patreon
all right so Gavin Dottie asks John
vervain key talks about the need for
synoptic integration and for him he
seems to do this through cognitive
science well you do so through
Christianity rebecky also says he's not
an eclectic though I'm not sure exactly
how at least some of what he's
advocating isn't a kind of mythological
eclecticism what does a non eclectic
assimilation look like to you the dying
and rebirth you talk about and do you
think buddhism taoism and company will
have to do to be better assimilated by
christianity going forward in order to
confront the unwise AI future for Mickey
worries about um well yeah I I do think
I do agree that I think that John's
approach in the end is eclectic I know
he won't agree with me I do think that
it is I think that the difference that
we have is one of the things that I feel
like I've understood very clearly is
that you have to exist inside a story
and so science is not a story we are in
this Christian story you can't help it
we are in 2019 after the birth of Christ
that's the story we're in and so there
are some things which are not for us to
decide and so if you decide that you
will not be in that story in the West
you can do that but you will be a you
will be a vehicle of subversion there's
no way around it you will be a vehicle
of subversion now I'm not saying that
sometimes subversion isn't needed
sometimes subversion is needed because
we've talked about this before because
you know that because Christianity can
become corrupt
christiana can become pharisaic and can
become hypocritical can become
sentimental can become all these things
and so I do sometimes it might
need to be poked you know act from the
outside I agree but it's important to
understand that if you if you think that
you can be a Taoist in Wisconsin
you know you let's say that the place
that you have is going to be a marginal
place you will have a marginal place and
and and and I say that you have to
understand that I say that it's not
totally a criticism because I myself I
became Orthodox orthodoxy is not totally
from here orthodoxy has a hint of the
eccentric it has a hint of the foreign
in terms of of our terms of let's say
Western Christianity and I think but of
course I think that it has just enough
hint of the foreign to be a renewing
agent for for for the West
you know that's my that's my impression
that I mean I don't know how things are
gonna play themselves out but that's one
of the reasons let's say why I moved in
that direction um now I don't think that
it's I don't think that we can't learn
from other traditions I have no problem
with people reading Taoist text reading
Buddhist texts reading reading Sufi
texts you know but I think especially
considering that so much of let's say
the mystical language of Christianity
has been lost has been corrupted has
been you know has been trampled to hunt
by materialism so I don't have a problem
with with trying to to using let's say
using things that you find outside to
kind of help you but the hope is that
then it'll point you towards the inside
that it'll help you re and the the
metaphysics of Christianity we
understand the mystical reality of
Christianity that to me is the is the
hope and in terms of the story this is
where something has to happen there's
something that we can't decide as
individuals we can't decide
of us as individuals decides when you
know when the story changes there's
something has to happen like you know
like like the arrival of a prophet like
the return of Christ like the like the
you know like a disaster like whatever
there is there some things which you
know like a plague like a war like
they're all these things which change
the story but we don't at least very
very very very very very few of us have
any say in what the story is going to
the way the story is going to go and so
I think that it's best to it's best to
to be part of the Christian story that's
that's what I think as a you know as a
Western as a Western person I think that
that's the that's the story that's the
best story I mean I do I I think it's
the best story in general of course you
know I'm a Christian but uh yeah
and so I think that and so let's say and
do you think Buddhism Taoism and company
will have to better to be better
assimilated by Christianity going
forward in order to be confronted to
confront the unwise AI I don't know I
don't know what's gonna happen with that
I don't know I think that I mean it's
horrible that I had to say this but I
think that there's some things that are
going to happen it's not going to be
it's not going to be pretty it's not
going to be totally peaceful the way
things are going to play out there's
going to be upheavals I don't see I
don't see it happening in any other way
hopefully hopefully if if that happens
we'll have enough people with a heart to
uh you know to carry the seed so sorry
if I sound a bit negative guys all right
read Arnall asks while trying to wrap my
head around the book of Job I came
across Humes answer to joke for those
unfamiliar with the work it is well
summarized by Union scholar Murray Stein
in Young's interpretation job is
completely
innocent he's scrupulously pious man who
follows all the religious conventions
and for most of his life he's blessed
with good fortune this is the expected
outcome for a just man in a rationally
ordered universe but then God allows
saying to work on him bringing
misfortune and misery
being overwhelmed with questions and
images of divine majesty and power job
is then silence he realizes inferior
position because of you the Almighty but
he also retains his personal integrity
and this so impress is God that he is
forced to take stock of himself
perhaps he is not so righteous after all
yeah it's a bit shady as Marc Fonda
observes God's omniscience preclude
self-awareness being omniscient God has
no concentrated self to speak of being a
part of everything God has no
opportunity to display extinguished self
from non-self whoever God as God knows
the thoughts of humans though the
thoughts of how long is this quote here
the thoughts of his creation he can
experience what self-awareness is and
out of his astonishing self-reflection
induced in God by job's stubborn
righteousness he the Almighty is pushed
into a process of transformation that
leads eventually to his incarnation as
Jesus hmm God develops empathy and love
through his confrontation with job and
out of his it a new relationship between
God and humankind is borne uncooked
that's a long quote this is
controversial to say the least but at
least very interesting idea to play with
any thoughts I don't yeah I don't buy it
I don't buy I don't buy that at all I
don't buy that I think maybe young
doesn't know anything about the Trinity
maybe that's why he said something like
that God is God is the whole idea of
Father Son and Holy Ghost is exactly to
speak of that that that distance and
connection the the the the the knowing
the logos knowing the father through
love and then it's and the Holy Spirit
you know the Trinity is is a form of
self knowing so anyways and I just I
just think this is it is this is not I
don't I don't know I'm not impressed by
this
all right sorry okay so so uh what is
there something else I can say about
this let's see if I there's something
else I could say about this okay so in
in in the in in in terms of the
incarnation of Christ in in the Orthodox
tradition and I think in the medieval -
in the medieval tradition the the higher
aspects of the medieval tradition let's
say the Incarnation to a certain extent
was always the purpose of creation that
is the purpose of creation was to for
God to sell also to know his creation -
to kind of you know to create something
that he could love and unite to himself
you know without without destroying it
and so that's the life of God is love
and the creation participates in that
life of love and the Incarnation was the
the purpose from the beginning it's only
that the you know Adam had to depending
how you see it either you can see it as
Adam wasn't able and fell and then
there's a detour or even in st. Irenaeus
you get the sense that Adam and Eve were
rather like children and that to a
certain extent the fall is a form of was
all not that the fall was necessary but
that the fall participates in this
bigger story and that Adam and Eve to a
certain extent you know because they
were innocent children they had to fall
and then to come and bring about the
actual Incarnation which was the summit
and the met the maturing of the human
person so maybe that helps a little more
so so sorry red I've told you guys
before that I'm not I'm not a young it's
not a young fan everybody tell me you
need to read you already read more young
so maybe one day I will but at least for
now I don't know all right all right so
drew McMann asked I can't remember if it
was a Twitter post or a video clip where
you said that
is hell can you expand on what you mean
by that we're all in the process of
dying so are we in hell I've always
thought death was natural and a
necessary part of life but I've recently
heard some more that I think as claiming
death is not natural is this the case I
need a total mind shift on how to look
at the world well hell means death hell
is death it's just the same we have a
confusion we have this weird confusion
about death we somehow think when we
think of Hell usually we think of this
idea of the eternal fire but the eternal
fire is not hell hell really is death
it's fine if you use the word hell for
for the eternal fire that's fine
but death held that the God the goddess
of think hell is a god I'm like a
northern god of death like Hades
basically so so so Hades is death it's a
you know the shale you know death and so
yes it is in Christian theology in all
Christian theology death is viewed as
not natural it is viewed as a as a
consequence of the fall it is viewed as
something of forgetting of of your
source of forgetting of your origin you
know and you have to understand it like
this you have to understand death as as
a form of decomposition it's probably
the best way to understand death it's
when things break apart and are no
longer held together by logos okay and
so death is a consequence of of a
forgetting it's a consequence of a
forgetting but it it holds also a
mystery there's a mystery in death which
is that that multiplicity can also be a
form of glory and I and I talked about
this before so there's also this idea
that we can we can transcend death
through death and so that
that this this entering into
multiplicity if there's memory can be a
form of of glory I don't know how else
to say it and so it is true that death
is not natural but the the process of
death also hides something else
HEIs a way to flip it to to flip it so
that it becomes that it becomes
resurrection they becomes glory then
becomes all that so hope that answered I
can't
I can't tell you totally the I can't
reveal to you the extent of this because
I don't understand it I don't understand
the extent of this I can get hints of it
I sometimes I get these hints of what
that is then when you read the story of
the Saints and you see you know these
these saints that are transfigured that
are you know or if you get if you have
stories of this notion of Elijah or
Enoch that I send or you or that Moses
his body was taken up into heaven it's
like I don't totally understand what
that don't totally understand what that
means
I can intuitively get a sense of it and
I can also see that it's true at little
I can see that being true at little
levels but but I don't I don't
understand the fullness of it but I
understand enough about it to trust the
just a pattern and to trust the story
and to know that the pattern is is is
manifesting something real alright I
hope that I hope that answers alright
okay so where are we alright so Michael
Parsons asks are human hands hands with
thumbs and consciousness a form of
technology they increase our positive
and negative capacity but the
categorical lines are blurred because
they are proper to the human body
you cannot wield a sword without a hand
and you cannot create a sword without
conscious mind to me it is interesting
also considering the
mind and hand are on the extremities of
the human body the periphery as opposed
to the center but the heart is in the
center what are your thoughts on hands
and mind consciousness as forms of
Technology also when you think about the
idea that loves the center all right so
let's answer this question first okay so
I mean I think we have to be careful not
to confuse confuse some things I
wouldn't say I've certainly would say
that consciousness is a form of
Technology I would say that there is a
form of knowledge which leads to
technology and we usually say it's art
or technique you know technical
knowledge and so for example in the
Greek thinkers techne was opposed to
epistemic so there's this notion of
looking towards the principles looking
towards the the source of things looking
towards the Logie you know you could say
that contemplating the reasons for
things - that that things exist you know
that's kind of the meditative the prayer
the the the gathering yourself into
yourself towards those higher principles
and then there's the technique which is
using the principles you understand to
affect the world you know power and so
so it's not that power or or Tecna or
the capacity to act on the world and the
will to act on the world that's what
will bring about technology and there's
a connection between the two but to say
that hands uh okay so you could say you
could actually see that your body your
physical body is all in that process
your physical body is the garments of
skin it is your capacity to act in the
world and so it's not just hands that
are that our tech nailer that that are
akin to technique akin to power to act
in the world but your whole
you know is has that as well and so I'm
not sure that consciousness
I mean consciousness is more like the
center right it's more like I mean then
from consciousness you could look down
or look up look towards the world or
then you know contemplate the the the
the principle so it is more like that
like the heart you could say and so
that's what I guess it brings me to the
other question then which is yeah which
is that that hands the mind and hand are
on the extremities of the human body the
periphery as opposed to the center yeah
the thing about the head is that the
head is the summit so there's a
relationship between the head and the
summit or the top the top of a mountain
or the top of you know there's all this
symbolism in the Bible about the head
you know the head of the household the
head of there's there's a hierarchical
element that makes the head akin
something somehow akin to the heart but
the heart is is more the center in the
sense that that's where everything comes
together the heart is where even
physically like this this place here
right here in the middle that's where
you experience let's say the unity of
your self when you experience the the
it's where you experience your emotions
that's where you experience you know
your calm your you know the the basic
pattern of your life you know you kind
of experiments you experience it here
and so that relates also to the heart in
a more metaphysical sense the place
where you know your mind and your body
come together the place where the the
top and the bottom come together would
be you know in this this kind of central
central space alright okay so what
do you think about the idea that love is
the sentiment physically as the thing
that we should circumambulate around
through Christ as well as physically in
the body with the human heart I mean I
love is that love is is them is the mode
of being love is not the logos love is
you say God is love in the sense that
love is the the mode of being of the
infinite the mode of being of God so I
mean you could say God is love but it's
not it's not so obvious to say that love
is God I don't think that that's that's
that's a good way to see it the mode of
being of God is love and so love is the
manner in which you can even
circumambulate because you are joining
yourself and you know you are coming to
that Center you're seeing it at the
center you're also seeing your your
distance from it and so you're kind of
circumambulating is it related to to
love alright
all right second a report from an
evolutionary perspective the mind
consciousness is an advancement in
technology as an increase in animal
capacity from a hybrid evolutionary
biblical perspective it could seem that
the acquisition of these technologies
are a type of fall are moving into death
but again the heart existed long before
thumbs in the conscious mind and and
seems to give more credibility to the
idea that love should be at the center
hmm this makes me think more about what
the imago Dei actually is first thing I
believe it is something like our
capacity to create through love like you
I believe evolution happen but do not
believe in it I do believe that Christ
is that image of God and that it is only
through Christ that we can access this
kind of creation by binding us into a
cohesive moral community amongst other
things I could say more but I think
since long enough already
I would love to hear your thoughts on
and if these ideas that if you are in
contact with the North electrician
perspective um yeah I think it's I think
it's scary you know okay so I don't know
I think it's scary to mix the mix some
of these things together like to take to
take kind of scientific thinking and
then to have your story thinking and to
mix them together you know I say that I
mean Durham Peterson does it all the
time but sometimes sometimes he freaks
me out with something with that too but
I actually kind of careful to to kind of
confuse different different ways of
speaking about the world um but for sure
it liked it let me say this let me say
this okay for sure the idea okay so okay
so you can if you're attentive to
yourself okay if you're attentive to
yourself and if you're attentive to
other people you can perceive where
their being is in their body and I would
suggest that you do that sometimes I
walk on the street and you can you look
at people and you can see where they're
where they tend to position
they're being you know and there are
some people who exist in their hands
there are some people that exist in
their head you see it you see that
they're up here some people are in their
shoulders see guys you know their
shoulders some people are in their hips
some people are in other places and so
in in the in the in the Fela Kalia and
the mystical tradition of the Orthodox
Church it does talk about this idea of
entering into the heart and withdrawing
from the outer senses so the hands you
know and the other like your sexual
senses and then you know your you know
your other sense even your eyes and your
ears and everything they're kind of like
this
these portals to the outside world and
they're also they're also the place in
which you come into contact with that
the things that a light that wake up
your passions let's say okay you know
you see something you're jealous of it
you want to take it you you know you see
all of that it happens out here and so
there is there is a sense in in the
Orthodox tradition where you need to
retreat from your senses you have to
enter into the heart so there's
obviously a spiritual aspect to that
which is to kind of to withdraw from
your thoughts to kind of eliminate the
extraneous thoughts to focus on prayer
focus on the Jesus Prayer we call it but
then there's also an actual kind of
physical sense that you have to retreat
from your senses and and and and exist
in and have come into the center of
yourself as well right you you can
experience it somewhat physically in the
sense that you are that you're going to
focused in on yourself start to explain
this stuff and you kind of have to start
to explain this stuff but there's an
analogy there is an analogy between
where you are where you kind of exist in
your your body as you you
you go through your day and let's say
the spiritual centeredness of yourself
you know there's an analogy between the
two the body isn't totally devoid of
participation in this process so if you
like if you're like none of this of what
I'm saying here is clear
hopefully it is I probably shouldn't be
talking about this stuff especially the
mystical stuff Ganon should be talking
about that stuff all right all right
okay here we go
so annual Terpstra in your reading list
on patreon you recommended to read
meister eckhart now I already have read
some sermons from a small paper I've
written on his hermeneutics in my
experience however I found it quite
difficult to really grasp what he is
saying and also his interpretation
struck me as somewhat speculative
nonetheless I think he's an interesting
figure so I was wondering what it is
that you find so compelling about
Eckhart why did you put him on your
reading list and what do you think about
his idea that God is becoming besides
that I would like to ask if Eckhart is
less problematic from an orthodox
perspective since he was condemned as a
heretic by the Catholic Church well
first of all Eckhart was not condemned
as a heretic by the Catholic Church
that's really important to understand
the way that the Catholic Church works
if he some of it card statements were
condemned as heretical by the Catholic
Church a lot of thinkers there have had
their some of their phrases condemned by
the Catholic Church we don't even know
which phrases that Eckhart said which
were condemned the reason why I I liked
Eckhart is because I wanted to be fair
in my reading list and I wanted to
suggest some Western authors because a
lot of the authors are a lot of the
subjects that I was I was pointing to
were mostly Eastern mystics and so I
wanted to point to a Western mystic who
who seems to have believed in
some form of theosis that is in some
form of capacity to be fully and truly
United with God and so that's something
that I that I found in Eckhart now when
you say that his idea that God is
becoming I'm not sure that that's the
reading that I got from Eckhart if what
you mean is that God is is dynamic then
I think that you're right there in in in
eastern Christianity user research
Christianity does not believe that God
is a form is a stasis is a form of
stasis but rather that that the love
between that love which exists in the
Trinity is a is a dynamic whole and so
there is a dynamism in God within the
Eastern tradition so I don't know if
that's what you mean
um and so I don't know I know I don't
know what a lot of words that people
think about a cart I actually did find I
found his sermons to be quite
illuminating
for a a Western person to see the extent
of of mysticism which existed in the
West I think is it's good for us to be
aware of that all right here we go
okay so Nolan Watson asked is there a
way to explain the church's rejection of
same-sex marriage in symbolic terms
uh-huh alright so Nolan I think I think
that it's interesting because I think
that your your your your question is
phrased in an odd manner and and I think
that it's good - it's good to notice
that and it's good to think for
everybody to think about that about the
manner in which the question is framed
and a lot of the problem related to - to
same-sex attraction and same-sex
is often about a often about a problem
of how we phrase questions the idea that
the church rejects same-sex marriage
it's very interesting because it's it's
it's it's interesting that it's phrased
that way rather than phrase the other
way which is how did our society today
come to reject the the eternal people
the all cultural all all historical
definition definite there are some
definitions but a basic definition of
marriage and so that's how I would
phrase that question not the other way
around
but I think that we can definitely see
it let's say the question of sexuality
definitely has symbolic terms I talked
about this in a in a YouTube discussion
called the resurrection of logos which I
with Joran Peterson I did an event at
the University of Toronto but symbolism
is really the bringing together of
things of different elements gathering
them together in order for there to be a
coherent for you to perceive and to
engage in a coherent pattern okay and so
in the in the I notions of st. Maximus
you know the logos the purpose the
reason the essence of something gathers
its particularity is together into a
coherent whole and so sexuality does
that to a very large degree and so
sexuality has many elements it has it
has many aspects to it and one one of
the one of the major aspects is that it
unites it's a uniting of opposites it's
the uniting it's analogically the
uniting of heaven and earth together of
the masculine and the feminine you know
the
in the yang it's this union of these two
complementary opposites together and
when that union of complimentary
opposite happens then there's a fruit
there's fruitfulness to that and that is
the child okay and so that's why the the
image of the union of them of the man
and the woman in sexual union becomes
the image of the of the church and
Christ becomes the image of God and the
soul and so this image of sexuality
becomes the very manner in which the
image of the very manner in which we are
united with with God okay and the
different elements of of sexuality have
to kind of exist in in the pattern you
know I always I always say I always like
to use the example of food in turn and
you know in order for us to understand
it's like food has different aspects to
it in food there is a nutritional aspect
which is to preserve and continue life
in food there is an aspect which is a
social aspect which is to bring us
together and we eat together it creates
a bond for a building of community and
food also has an aspect which is to
bring you pleasure and so if you
emphasize only one of those then you're
missing the full pattern if you
emphasize if you emphasize only the
nutritional aspect then you're you're
going to miss on a great aspect of what
food is for the human person if you
focus only on the pleasure then then you
also will miss the nutrition you'll
become fat you'll become diabetic you'll
you know all of that is going to happen
and if you and it the same for the the
social aspect and so all of those have
to have to come together in
to be a coherent pattern now the thing
is that it doesn't mean that everything
you eat has to for example be totally
nutritional doesn't mean that everything
you eat has to be something which brings
the community together but this all of
this has to exist within a pattern so
that's one of the problems when when
people talk about sexuality it's like
there's an excess I believe even it was
in Christianity which is this idea that
almost it's almost like every time you
have a sexual encounter you should have
a child it's like I don't think that
that's the proper way to see it but then
there's also this notion that somehow
the sole purpose of sexuality is for it
to be a playground you know to to to to
uh to explore your desires and your
pleasure and then there's another aspect
which is that you know it doesn't matter
who it is it doesn't matter what what
people as long as it brings you together
and creates this this couple you know
but the truth is that the Christian
vision of sexuality is that all of those
have to come together and it becomes an
image of reality itself it becomes in
and and it becomes an image it becomes a
participation in reality because it
that's what it makes it perpetuates
Society it perpetuates it physically in
perpetuated by creating families which
are the core of society and and and the
love of the man and the woman in the
couple is going to also perpetuate the
the cohesion of society and then those
families join together and our our
communities and so that's that that's
that's the positive vision of sexuality
for for Christians and that's the vision
of marriage I think for many many
cultures there are some exceptions of
course with polygamy but but the basic
pattern is still the same in terms of
you know how things work in order for
society to to to be functional and so
yeah I don't know I don't know I don't
know what else to say about that
I always see it in terms of a positive I
don't see it in terms of a negative I
see it as an understanding a beautiful
powerful understanding of what the logos
of sexuality is what the purpose is and
understanding that we all fall short of
that you know understanding that we all
all we you know that in our thoughts and
interactions that we don't we all fall
short of it but still understanding that
that's the ideal and that's the that's
the logos and that's what we should be
striving towards in terms of how we how
we live our sexuality so yeah I hope
that answers your question guys
all right so Laura Jill asks as a
Catholic with a deep interest in Eastern
Orthodoxy you have an opinion about
Eastern Rite Catholics all right I think
I hear and that's that's the other
question I hope that my my first answer
gave you gave you an answer to that says
in particular she see she feels strongly
she would like to see increased dialogue
between ancient churches and I agree I
totally agree I think that that we need
to continue to talk and to speak to each
other and to to understand the
differences and to work to resolve them
in a real way not in a knotted like I
said not in a political way not in a not
in a just pretending they don't exist
but really you know continue to dive
into it and and hopefully by the grace
of God one day we will have actual true
communion between the churches so so
Jessica Gabe asks in Orthodox
iconography what is the significance of
what appears to be ribbons emanating
from the necks of angels also why are
the angels depicted with feminine
characteristics okay so the the ribbons
emanating from the necks of angels are
not emanating from their necks they are
emanating from Gaia so I have it here
here's my icon it's a Michael they are
emanating from the headband
okay so the angel has a headband which
holds the hair and then it's tied in the
back and then the the ribbons are are
floating floating out and so why do they
look like that you'll hear crazy crazy
you leave crazy theories about that but
I think that my theory is quite sound it
is simply to show that they're floating
it is simply to show the floating when
you see floating cloth it is often to
suggest a form of of spirituality it's
like there's wind blowing or there
they're floating you know obviously we
don't have time we don't want to
understand it in materialistic terms
it's an imagery to show this notion of
of spirituality of likeness of something
which is floating and so you see these
floating ribbons that are kind of
floating as if there's you know that the
the you know the the are the Archangel
is kind of floating up in the air okay
you see that often in when you see
Christ at there at the resurrection at
the Resurrection icon you see his you
see his vestments have this floatiness
to it you know and you see that here
like right here at sea for example you
see say mom is here has this floaty
floaty cloth and so it's much really is
to show this this kind of spiritual
lightness that they that the character
has that's the way I understand it as
well
and why are angels depicted with
feminine characteristics they're not
there they are not supposed to be
depicted with feminine characteristics
they're supposed to be represented with
androgynous characteristics because they
are not sexed they they are neither male
nor female and so that's why they're
represented usually the way that the way
that it's kind of understood is that
they they have something when you would
call kind of boyish you know kind of
like a young young man or like a or a
young woman you know where where you
know the man hasn't doesn't have a lot
of beard yet or you know
a kind of neutral neutral look so it is
then androgynous aspect alright alright
guys so I have gone through the
questions let me let me scroll down the
the YouTube questions and see see if
we've had something interesting here so
HR Callum asked is it beneficial
Christians to really get to know our
dark central side or evil tendencies by
studying atrocities or evil deeds of
people for instance because the Bible is
call us to understand evil I would say
that it's probably better to study your
own evil and atrocities rather than
study other people's evil and atrocities
confession is really good for that
just compunction in general seeing all
those side thoughts you know all that
every time you judge someone every time
you you are angry every time you have
weird
power fantasies or you know whatever it
is that you find in yourself I would say
that that's probably a much more useful
way to go than to study atrocities in
the world I mean we need to be aware of
atrocities but there is also and and we
need to understand that we have seen it
happen but there is I think I don't know
I don't know I think there is a a there
could be a perverse pleasure in that and
I mean I felt it myself
you know when i some point of listening
to podcast i was in the different
podcast they always show you know like
on the the app they always show you all
these true-crime podcasts and I'm like
okay I'll check that out so I started
listening to the true crime podcast and
mmm not sure not sure it was it was it's
helpful not sure it's helpful you know
because there's a kind of weird dark
fascination that we have with now the
same fascination that makes you watch
horror movies or that makes you watch
that kind of stuff so yeah not sure okay
all right so land BRR
land bort asks hey Jonathan I have an
icon question for you how was the
general style of iconography developed
and how do we know these images best
reflect the divine the the best way to
understand how the style of iconography
developed is to understand it as an
aesthetic practice that is there was
Roman art which was very extremely
central and extremely flamboyant and the
church basically removed all the excess
and you know remove the extra curves
remove the central bodies and kept most
of Roman art but but let's say strained
it out you know and so that was the work
that the church that the church did and
that's why I cannot refer looks the way
that it does and I think that the reason
why it is the best style I don't know if
we would say that it reflects the divine
but to the extent that something can
reflect the divine I think that this
aesthetic concentration and the capacity
to concentrate the form is is probably a
good a good answer to that all right I
Paterson asks I would be interested in
picking up again on the civil ISM of
water and the old the Old Testament and
New Testament especially the contrast
between Jonah in the fish and Paul
shipwreck did we talk about that was it
you David who asked that I'm not sure I
don't think I'm gonna go back into that
right now because it's getting late
maybe you could ask a more specific
question next time and then I can either
think about it and do a video about it
or something can you say that the logos
so Luke Fleischman asks can you say that
the logos is the most natural thing
there is so the logos would be found
even in that which is unnatural I don't
know what the word unnatural means the
something which becomes unnatural is
something which is not in its proper
place that's what makes something
unnatural everything is good when it's
in its proper place and so that's what
that's what makes something unnatural
and that's why I talk about hierarchy
why I talk about monsters why I talk
about all that because I want you to
understand that in the whole picture
there's also that you know and so and so
I don't so I don't think that things
become unnatural when they are
rebellious you could say or when they
want more for themselves or when they
want to isolate themselves from the
whole when they want to think that
they're that they have the fullness of
reality within them and so that's that's
the problem with technology technology
is a problem only to the extent that
people see technology almost as a as a
means you know as an end in itself and
they or they see it as a means to fill
their own you know perverse desires but
technology in its technology as a thing
would not necessarily be what's not
necessarily bad there's a story the the
this someone asked me several people
asked me actually why is it that in the
in the in Tolkien's story Tom Bombadil
is not affected by the Ring of Power
and it's exactly that is that for the
innocent for those that are truly in the
heart for those that that are not are
not tripped on their own on all their
desires and all their externalities
those externalities are not dangerous to
them they are not and so the ring has
not cannot have an effect on someone who
is is in his heart and who has a an
innocence like a points an innocent
buoyancy you could say not naive not
naive Tay but a capacity to not be
seduced by the call of the of the the
kind of external things all right all
right guys I think I think we're done we
went a lot longer there's not a lot
longer about ten minutes longer than
usual so uh so yeah so thanks for that
everybody thanks for for coming on we
got got a lot of interesting questions I
think I'm gonna make the the QA public
this month because because I because I
said I was gonna answer the questions
about art and everything but we'll see
because I feel like I said a lot of
weird stuff tonight what to see it's why
I'm gonna make it public or not but uh
but yeah so thanks for coming coming by
everybody and and I will see you see you
guys next month